we should walk in there and see if we
could swing someone getting us in here
hey what's up oh rear
recording here we are at NAB 2015 there
go see all the cool cameras and all the
cool lights and all the cool drones
allen poe editing software that are
coming out this year all the sweet gear
you see in our behind-the-scenes videos
we usually see here first because this
is the show floor this is where they
have all the new toys there's a lot of
misconceptions about NAB it's not just
about radios anymore there's this new
kid in town called
computer software so recently Devin and
ourselves stopped to shoot a video
together in Minnesota and while we were
there he was telling me how they were
releasing a signature series of the
glidecam just for him something that he
actually helped create that's how you
know you've made it when you have a
piece of camera equipment with your
signature on it but you get all the TV
channels those dishes dude this is what
anyb is all about man so I've been
looking at the specs of all the new
cameras that were announced I'd say the
Blackmagic mini Ursa mini looks like
probably the next best thing for the
indie filmmaker out there so Sam thinks
the new black magic Ackerson mini is a
boring camera and not selective it's
really boring but I can really disagree
because for five thousand dollars from
dude 4k 15 steps range but the thing is
the high frame rates I prioritize over
just long 24 second attendant okay
everybody paid 5 grand for that 100 back
in the day we shot dubstep guns with
that and this thing blows have us 100
out of the water let me do time see it's
like a scarlet subscribe 5k don't you
hate when your antennas broken
I do I can totally poke people about
showing it's me nothing is it's not just
men called microphones came all day
they'll be flight GoPro you guys
remember in
insta-kill there's a knife shot because
you can you go throw up on me that
alright so right now I'm being lit by
the coolest lighting setup that we see
here so far it is Sam
it's called Sam Sam with a boom pole
with the light on it you know if you
like so now we can just put the softbox
wherever and get good lighting you would
look at these freaking antennas alright
so remember when you were watching movie
aliens and you're watching at perk
aliens well these guys at Red Rock
basically develop that exact system that
you're seeing in the movie and basically
of a rotating laser shooty thingy module
that goes out and shoots all your actors
with lasers and then translate those
lasers into mini map data where you can
see here take a look boom there's a mini
map and as she moves you could the
lasers are tracking her so you want to
focus on them or anyone in your scene
multiple people look homies check this
out so you look at this doubts there's
two of them I can click on one to pull
focus to her pull focus to him it's
incredible so this is the cage where the
drones fight
wonderful a is a phone gimbal here dude
they have they have gimbal exoskeletons
now
so practical my favorite superhero after
spending a day inside in in a well
air-conditioned room we have not walked
outside into legitimate Las Vegas dust
storm brought a scarf here's the
thing I don't know where I'm going them
same thing at nab this year
second radio does yeah but then every
cell and drones now those drones all
over the place hot rods on those we
haven't even seen a fraction about yeah
yeah usually what's more impressive
though than all the cool camera
equipment and gear that you find at
enemy is actually these people you run
into we've only been here for about five
hours but so far we've run into ready
we're gonna do Devin Graham and we've
run into numerous other colleagues to
people who work at Dolby and other
camera companies and stuff like that
because Ryan Connolly of course is their
match wits the guy yeah and the guy
they'd met I know it's crazy but the
thing is that like more than anything
else is is a great place to meet people
in the industry and other filmmakers who
are like-minded
so definitely uh there's more reasons to
come other than just lenses in gear